[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantine kissin and this is the
show for you
if you want honest conversations with
fascinating people
and a fascinating guest we have for you
today she is a former academic sex
researcher
neuroscientist and she is the author of
the upcoming book the end of gender
dr deborah soh welcome to trigonometry
hi guys
thank you for having me oh it's an
absolute pleasure we loved reading the
book
really fascinating stuff which we'll get
into in a moment but for anyone
who doesn't know who you are just tell
everybody who are you
how are you where you are what is the
journey that brings you here talking to
us through this weird medium
so i am a science journalist i write
primarily about the science of
gender and sex human sexuality i read
about the politicization of science and
also
academic censorship i can talk a bit
about how i
left academia ended up in journalism so
during the last few years of my phd my
phd
is in sexual neuroscience research and i
had noticed that the climate in academia
had changed so
i noticed there were more and more
topics that you couldn't really speak
about you can
researchers didn't want to touch because
they were growing increasingly
controversial
and they didn't want to deal with the
public backlash one issue in particular
had to do with
transitioning in young children with
gender dysphoria so at that time
pretty much every single mainstream used
piece would
say that if you have a young child with
gender dysphoria
the best way forward for them would be
to transition so that would
usually include you know getting a
different haircut taking on a different
name identifying as the opposite sex
every news piece was saying this is
really great for these kids the parents
would say that the child is doing so
much better after
but from a scientific perspective all of
the research available
shows that most of these kids who feel
gender dysphoric
the vast majority of them when they
reach puberty they will outgrow those
feelings
they're more likely to grow up to be gay
in adulthood and so i felt it was
important to say something about this
i wrote an op-ed and i waited about six
months to publish it because
i knew that there would be a lot of
backlash i wasn't sure if it was going
to be the right decision
i asked a number of my colleagues and
mentors and they were very supportive of
me
i remember one conversation in
particular with one mentor and i asked
him
should i wait until i have 10 years so
at that time i plan to stay in academia
i had a whole plan in terms of the
research i wanted to be doing
and he told me tenure would not protect
me so that was that sealed my decision
and i decided to have the op-ed
published and then since then i've
self-exiled from academia and i work as
a journalist and now i'm here speaking
with you
you are yeah how far you've fallen
but listen before we we get into the
subject matter itself
i i actually will just responding to
what you've just said i mean
tenure is the idea just for people like
us you're not into the academic world
is the idea that you have a job for life
right yeah it's protections because
the point of being an academic
especially a scientist is that you
should be able to
pursue novel research questions and not
be afraid of what you're going to find
so tenure essentially protects you that
no matter what you find i mean
most researchers are going to be
responsible and it's not like there it's
going to be a free-for-all and they're
going to go digging for
you know terrible things but it is you
need to be able to have that protection
if you're going to do your job properly
as an academic
and so definitely now i would say even
in 2020 it's so much
worse now there there's no such thing as
protection well
this is what i want to get into the the
institution of tenure was
designed specifically for this purpose
to allow scientists to research things
that may not be popular
in the moment so that they can't be
punished for you know
discovering the wrong thing let's say uh
what did what did that meant to mean
when they said tenure will not protect
you
like ten years supposed to protect you
why wouldn't that protect you
well especially within sex research
there's a very long and ugly history
of between sex researchers and
transgender activists
where if an expert says something that
upsets the activist groups
they will go after the researcher and
really try to destroy that person not
only that person's professional
reputation but their personal reputation
and their
their life and there was one case of one
sex researcher michael bailey who is a
professor of psychology at
northwestern university he published a
book in i believe it was 2003
um that really upset trans activists and
they went after him and they
in the in my book i talk about all the
things that they did
to him which were really terrible and
unethical
and uh so after that happened everyone
in sex research said you know this is
not something i want to go through i
don't
it's just not worth it so everyone just
stays quiet about these issues now
and so with that op-ed they were saying
to me and i knew too
you know if you say anything that upsets
activists and particularly transgender
activists
it's going to not be very nice for you
and why is it that people just don't
stand up to these people isn't that what
you meant to do with bullies just stand
up to them and say
and inside that that's unacceptable
you would think so and i think part of
what it is is academics are so busy with
their research and their core you know
their teaching they've got
administrative duties they're
pushed basically to their boundaries in
terms of what they're capable of as
human beings and they're exhausted all
the time so the last thing you want to
do is incite a mob and have to go on
social media and
fight with them so i think that's part
of it and i think also
activists are really empowered by
journalists and
and and i think the public to some
degree because people feel they're on
the quote unquote right side of history
by defending them
so it really is an uphill battle and
after you see a number of your
colleagues everyone
in sex research who has spoken up about
this gets
you know smeared gets attacked gets
mopped on social media and so i think it
has to be you have to have a very
specific personality to want to do that
and i'm sure you guys have that
personality but i think not everybody
does so
that that's how we got to where we are
and and deborah why
i still don't understand why is it so
toxic i mean
20 years ago that's a woman that's a man
we all agreed on it and then we went on
with our lives
why is it suddenly everybody kicking off
on the internet about it
i think part of it and i should
emphasize so i'm critical of
transitioning children i do support
transitioning in adults i do think
transitioning can help some people and
so especially for adults it's their
business i don't think anyone should be
telling them what they can and can't do
with their bodies
but i think part of this response
especially in the current age
is due to seeing what happened with the
gay rights movement now i'm a huge
supporter of gay rights and i grew up in
the gay community
and i think many people look back on
that period of homophobia and homophobia
still exists today in society but i do
think it's gotten
better to some degree i think people
look back on that and they say okay we
made so many mistakes in that way
so now going forward when it comes to
how people identify or anything that has
to do with
gender or sexuality um we're going to
fully support that and i think it's gone
so far in the opposite direction now
that anyone like myself
who who criticizes that even when
they're coming from a scientific
perspective
gets shouted down and told that they're
hateful and that they're bigoted and
that they're transphobic
okay and look there's some things
deborah that i'm gonna ask to clarify
because
like i said before i was understanding
this was a man this is a woman now i'm
very confused okay
what does the term gender is what is
gender what's the difference between sex
and gender
number one so sex biological sex
is determined by gametes so these are
mature reproductive cells so
you produce sperm or you produce eggs
the vast majority of people 99
of us our gender is our biological sex
so gender identity has to do with how
you feel
whether you feel masculine or feminine
gender expression is related to that in
terms of how you express your gender
identity so whether you
you know are gender conforming say
gender non-conforming
as a man you typically will be masculine
in the way you dress and the way you
carry yourself
and similar someone who's female is
going to be feminine
and with regard to gender dysphoria
gender dysphoria is
feeling as though a person identifies
more as the opposite sex than their
birth sex
okay now where does the term gender as a
social construct
come in because this is a term that
keeps being bandied about
what does that actually mean and do you
agree with it
i don't agree with it because it's not
true and people will say
that's very
you think the problematic is important
wow yeah we're gonna cancel for like the
tenth time this week
so uh what was i saying so gender is not
a social construct it's very much based
in biology and even for people who are
transgender there's a biological element
to
why they feel the way that they do so
gender
when people say gender is a social
construct it means that
uh gender roles are imposed by society
so people learn their gender
they're socialized to be masculine or
feminine and that and
usually tied into that is the idea that
there are no biologically
based sex differences between men and
women in the brain or in relation to
uh say occupational interests basically
anything across the board so if
your audience remembers the google memo
that happened in 2017
i wrote a column for the globe and mail
defending james damore
and then that that column got picked up
quite a bit and people were very upset
at me but
i feel it's again important to be
forthright about
these things the weird thing is though
gender the whole gender is a social
construct
this is reported now in mainstream news
and it's
repeated ad nauseum as though it's
true like there's no there's no people
don't back it up
they don't qualify it they simply just
say we know gender is a social construct
and they get on to saying whatever they
were saying and i'm thinking but that's
not true so it's
it's really crazy to me to see how this
science denial
is is just basically accepted at face
value
well isn't there a baron cohen study
which shows that day-old babies
uh male and female babies are attracted
to different things
male babies are attracted to objects and
female babe more attracted to objects
female babies are more attracted to
uh anthropomorphic type dolls and things
like that isn't that something just like
that obvious
so even babies are problematic
absolutely mate
well yeah because his research there
have been studies where they will
um take newborn babies and they will
find that
the females the girls will prefer
looking at faces and the boys would
prefer looking at mobiles or mechanical
objects
and so what then people who support the
argument that gender is a social
construct
they will say well these children have
already been born for so long and
they've managed to learn gender
stereotypes in the time i know i'm
looking at your face
my face isn't being shown to the
audience but that i'll make it
so that it's visible too they knew what
they
when did they when did they imbibe these
gender stereotypes
in in the womb well this is this is what
i say because there's research to show
that even in the womb before the brain
is finished developing there are
differences between male and female
fetuses
right unless someone wants unless
someone wants to argue that a child is
capable of learning gender stereotypes
before they're born which i would
honestly not be surprised if someone
were to argue that now because that's
how far this this conversation has gone
but i do understand you know and i think
since writing that column in
in 2017 i understand why people find
sex differences especially when it comes
to any biologically based ones why they
find it
so threatening um and you know mostly
women i think some men find it
threatening too because if you are in
favor of gender equality there's this
message that
you men and women have to be the same
and if there are any differences
this is due to sexism and we have to fix
that
and i think it's totally fine to
acknowledge that men and women are
different
but that doesn't mean one is better than
the other and as long as everyone is
content with
what they're doing in life if they don't
feel limited then that's really what
matters
i don't know if you would have seen our
interview with um posie parker
i did you did do you remember me having
a bit of a disagreement with her
or rather me trying to put the
counterpoint i suppose about
uh the brain so can you clarify that for
us
is there such a thing as a male brain
and a female brain
on average there are differences between
what you would find
typically and many typically in women so
that doesn't say anything about any
individual person so that's one
important point
and that's not to say there's not a lot
of overlap between the two as well
but statistically speaking if you look
on average at a group of
male versus female brains there will be
some differences
so it's not accurate to say that that
their you know brains are identical or
all right so let me just take that to
its logical conclusion which is what i
tried to do with her which is if there
is a difference on average between male
brains and female brains
would it not be therefore credible to
argue that somebody can be born
in a female body with a male brain and
so
the that yeah that is the common
understanding of uh when people say that
they
are transgender so with the research
that's available
with regard to brain imaging and trans
people um
they it does show that for say someone
who is a trans woman
her brain is slightly feminized so she
was born male identifies as female and
her brain is slightly in the direction
of
the sex she identifies as and similarly
for trans men so
trans men were born female identifies
male and their brains are shifted in the
direction again of the sex they identify
as
but the thing is with these studies they
are conflated with or confounded
with sexual orientation because everyone
who takes part in these studies
are also attracted to people who share
their birth sex so in sexology which is
the scientific study of sex and gender
which is my former discipline
when you talk about sexual orientation
in relation to people who are
transgender
it's in relation to their birth sex so
for a trans woman
who is again born male identifies as
female if she is attracted to men she's
considered
gay because she is attracted to
people who share her birth sex and so
similarly for
trans men if they are identi uh
attracted to
women then that's considered gay because
attracted again to people who share
their birth sex so
all this all of this is to say that in
the brain
there's a there have been shown to be
differences associated with
sexual orientation so when we look at
the brains of people who are transgender
versus people who are not transgender
with these studies we don't know if
those brain differences we're seeing
are due to them feeling transgender or
feeling gender dyswork
or due to the fact that they're
attracted to people who share their
birth sex and there was one study i
believe it was last year that got a lot
of attention media attention because it
was
showing in children with gender
dysphoria that they said their brains
are similar again
shifted in the direction of the sex they
identify as this shows that these
children
really are the other sex and that we
should support early transitioning
but again we don't the sexual
orientation of those kids was not
uh reported and so we you can't make
that
assumption and deborah you
are quite critical in the book about
allowing children to transition
now to me this seems as a former teacher
this seems fairly common sense but could
you explain to people
why is it that we shouldn't be allowing
children to transition
especially at a prepubescent age
as well as i mentioned a little bit
earlier in the interview the vast
majority of these kids
who feel that they were born in the
wrong body when they reach puberty
they're going to outgrow those feelings
of gender dysphoria and they're more
likely to identify as
gay in adulthood and so it doesn't make
sense for them to transition
at a young age before this point because
it would be completely unnecessary
and and research has shown that children
who even if they socially transition
because critics will say well a social
transition is nothing all you do is they
you know you give them a different name
and they can easily change their mind
but social transitioning is associated
with persistence of gender dysphoria so
children who do
take on a name of the sex that they
identify as and are treated as though
they are they are the opposite sex are
more likely to go on than to
seek other interventions in terms of
medically
and it's it's difficult i think too for
kids to
come back from that i mean i think
people really underestimate
how difficult and it can be for a child
to say you know i thought i was the
opposite sex but now i'm not and i've
talked to the
transitioners about this we can talk
about that too who will say
that it's it can be very embarrassing to
get everyone in your life to call you
you know the opposite sex and the new
name and say that you're sure about this
and then say actually no i i wasn't sure
about it
i'm actually curious but when you say
that france about you fail as a teacher
that's obvious why is that because
the feeling i get from a lot of people
is that well of course we would help
them
transition why wouldn't we i mean that's
actually what i used to think i used to
think of course put them on
on these drugs to help them well no the
reason i thought is because i know
children and a child
is not capable of making those decisions
at such a young age
well you were no far better than me but
a child is not able to
i think it comes at the age of four 14
15 well but as certainly as a 10 11 year
old they're not able to understand
consequences
a lot of the time you see teachers
telling off a child and saying well what
do you think would happen
when you did eggs and the kid shrugs its
shoulders because it doesn't understand
consequences
so essentially you're asking a child to
make a life-changing decision
before they understand that concept to
me it seemed ludicrous
but then maybe i'm just problematic
but you see this also i mean kids as
young as age three are being taken to
gender clinics so i'm thinking
three-year-olds have no three eight
three they have no idea what they're
saying at that point
and parents i think part of it is
parents are seeing all of this and
you know news coverage and they're
talking to their parents and they
they're some of them i think genuinely
think maybe that their child needs
treatment but i think some other parents
are really excited about this because it
means their child is special and that
this might be
you know some form of i don't think the
majority of parents feel this way but i
think there are some who
who really revel in that and what is the
rate of detransition with these kids is
it quite a lot of them a significant
amount of them or is it quite a low
amount
so there was one study in sweden that
showed that two percent of people who
underwent a
change in terms of the sex marker on
their government id
subsequently went and changed it back to
their birth sex but that
is in adults and that that study the
data collection i believe was done in
2011. so there we don't have data in
terms of
young children we don't have a data in
terms of especially this more recent
spike in terms of rapid onset gender
dysphoria which we're seeing
predominantly in young adolescent girls
um so i can talk about rapid onset
gender dysphoria as well but
we just don't know at this point so i
see it being very very um unfortunate
and
ugly what's coming in a couple of years
well this is the point and you talk
about rapid onset gender dysphoria might
be helpful for our audience if you
define it but if
if i give you my kind of layman
understanding is
over the last few years there's been a
massive increase like 4 000
or something crazy in the number of
young girls
and young women who who seem to
decide to transition in clusters in
other words it like happens
at a school that a lot of the girls
there suddenly all transition
is that broadly speaking correct yeah
yeah it is um so
what will usually happen is one of these
young women
their their close friend will come out
as a trans boy
and then the next thing you know she
comes home from school and tells her
parents
i want to be a boy and the parents are
really at a loss because if you take a
child to a gender clinic they have to
affirm that child
so in terms of the the prevalence so
lisa littman did a study in 2018 about
this
and she found that among friend groups
40 of these girls would have at least
half of their friend group identifying
as transgender which is
a lot and this is 70 times the what you
would normally find
in the general population in terms of a
statistical prevalence of adults who
identify as transgender so
and why it more more more likely now
because it used to be that it was mainly
males that would transition effeminate
males let's say
not i'm not saying that in a judgmental
way just in a kind of descriptive way
they would transition they were much
more likely to transition than women
now that seems to have been completely
changed in such a short period of time
why do you think it is that
girls are doing this
i think for many of them they're
experiencing discomfort in their bodies
which is very normal
that's a normal part of growing up
reaching puberty and
adolescence everyone feels awkward and
uncomfortable but instead now they're
being told
on social media and and everywhere
basically that if you are uncomfortable
with
your sex that you must be the opposite
sex so if you are a woman who doesn't
like it having her period
or you don't like male attention
potentially
that that means you should be a man and
no one is saying to them because it's
considered transphobic to say so to say
it's okay to feel different
as a young woman and especially for a
lot of them they have
other mental health conditions like
autism a lot of them have anxiety
they have eating disorders they're
self-harming and
this is a way for them to cope with the
way they're feeling
and i think too you know i'm very
critical of a lot of feminist
dogma but i do think in some ways
society can still be sexist
and for these young women it's an easy
way to avoid sexism
or homophobia also if they're a lesbian
a lot of these young women are lesbian
and
so to them it's it's easier to be a man
than to be a lesbian woman and do you
think part of the problem as well
again going back to my teaching
experience i saw social media come in
particularly
instagram particularly the pressure it
puts on young girls to look a certain
way their bodies to be a certain shape
or whatever else
and it's just a very easy way just to go
i want no part of this
i'm going to be completely different and
now i'm going to be
i'm not going to have to abide by those
rules yeah i would agree with that and i
think also pornography from what i've
been told by speaking with these young
women who have de-transitioned
they will be exposed to porn at a very
young age you know
that's just how it is everyone on the
phone now it's it's you know very easy
to get access and
they'll say i don't they think that
that's what sex real
life sex is going to be like they don't
realize that pornography is
entertainment and this is really
the peak moment of of sex between
two people or however many people so you
know they think i don't want that i
don't want to be objectified like that
they don't want to be objectified by
society understandably so and
so again this is a way to just avoid the
whole thing you know it sounds
so tragic what you're describing because
you know
you're saying you're what you're
basically saying is these young women
are already vulnerable
and we've created a structure for them
that affirms choices that don't actually
match who they are
but at every step of the way the adults
are going oh yeah yeah this is the right
way for you to go
now if if you are right and i suspect
that you are
then that wave of the transitioners that
you're talking about
is coming and i mean that's going to be
even worse because
there's going to be thousands of people
who've gone through
a very invasive process in many cases uh
being i mean just horrified of what
what what they've done to themselves and
what the adults around them allowed them
to do isn't that
is i mean is that coming oh yeah yeah
it's i mean it's already partially here
i would say over in the uk
i think you guys are seeing it the start
of it before north america
people are still very much in denial
about it because what you will hear when
if you talk about de-transitioners
de-transitioners are
supposedly a quote-unquote myth and then
it's it's statistically so rare
it never happens but those people were
never really trans those people were
never really gender dysphoric
and that that's not true and you know i
also criticize in the book the
non-binary movement because
i think this is similar in that so
before
it would very much be if if someone
wants uncomfortable with their birth sex
they will
identify as transgender now there's also
non-binary
which with that community comes for many
people having a double mastectomy so
again i have no issue people want to try
on different genders or identities i
think that's normal as part of the
development
developmental process but when you start
getting involved with surgery
and when we're not actually talking
about what this is really about
you know that's that's my issue i think
it's one thing if we could have these
conversations
and these individuals were saying i
still think this is the right thing for
me then i would feel a bit more
comfortable but
you can't have that conversation i think
people are going to be very upset by
what i say in the book because
these are things you're not supposed to
say but i think they need to be said
and do you think part of the problem as
well is that you know these people these
children are identifying as trans
without realizing that if you're a trans
person you're essentially going to
become
medicalised for the rest of your life
yeah and i at that age like you're
saying they're they're not
fully developed cognitively in terms of
their emotional maturity i don't think
they're necessarily thinking that far
ahead and this is why i'm appalled at
the adults
why why are parents and medical
professionals not
seeing this for what it is but i think
they similarly have been cowed either
they're afraid
of being called transphobic in some
cases you can lose your license we
actually have a law in canada that's
trying to be passed right now to
actually send someone to prison if they
could
they conduct so-called conversion
therapy which conversion therapy for
sexual orientation is not
acceptable i don't i don't support that
at all because it does not work it's not
ethical
conversion therapy for gender identity
does not exist
if you have a clinician who sits down
with a child and wants to understand
what else is going on in their life that
may lead them to feeling gender
dysphoric
that's considered conversion therapy now
where gender identity
in children is more flexible with age so
a child
again who says there are the opposite
sex can grow to feel comfortable in
their birth sex with age and i don't
think it's
considered it should be considered
transphobic to say that but now
mental health professionals cannot have
these conversations they cannot do a
proper assessment with these children
so they really just have to allow them
anyone to anyone who wants to transition
is basically the complete opposite of
medical gatekeeping now
so anyone who is against this they they
don't work with these patients anymore
so so what what do you do as a parent so
for instance a friend of mine
her daughter at the age of 11 years old
told her that she wanted to
transition and she didn't say if she
said when i transition
what what does a parent do if every all
the authorities
all the medical professionals seem to be
pushing this
kid down one particular path which is
going to
change her body and mutilate it forever
i think the number one thing for parents
every parent that i've spoken to has
said that taking a child to a gender
clinic actually makes
things worse because the it
it feeds into it it doesn't they don't
challenge the child right so then it
becomes an issue of
the child is then turned against the
parent and
now these kids are being encouraged to
if you're if your parents or people in
your life your family don't support you
cut them off so that can be you know
very very devastating for the parents i
would say
just love your kid i have some
suggestions i interviewed one of my
colleagues
dr susan bradley who is a world expert
in autism and gender dysphoria
and so she had some really good
suggestions in terms of what to do and
how to keep the conversation going with
your child and
and i think just one thing i would say
is try to limit the exposure your child
has to social
media which is i guess something to
start at a younger age just to try and
keep them off those platforms as much as
possible because that's really
where this ideology starts and it's it's
really strong because kids
you know they are very malleable and
when they're exposed to this and they
think
i feel different and this is the
solution to the way i feel
i think it can be really a an addictive
thing to grab onto and there is a link
as well
between autism and children that
transition
has that been fully explored or is that
just something that we're noticing
no it's very very common and even in
that study uh on rapid onset gender
dysphoria i can't remember the exact
number
the percentage but there was definitely
a correlation there
so that's the other thing because you
know i think
people with autism again deserve respect
and love and
and we should be able to say you know if
this is some if this is what is leading
you to feel a certain way because for
some people who
are with autism they are very um
they fixate on things so they'll go
through periods of being really really
into especially children they'll go
through periods of being really into
one thing like a toy and then they'll be
into something else and something else
and so gender could be one of those
topics that they
latch on to and they're really into for
a while but eventually it will pass
not to say that's the case for all of
them because there are some kids right
who do end up persisting
but um i think in today's climate you
it's really difficult for us to be able
to tease apart who's going to
legitimately persist and who's going to
desist or
not feel that way anymore because we're
again we're not talking about that
we're not talking about any other any
other potential explanations for the way
someone feels
so what would be a healthy way um to
treat people
who present as having gender dysphoria
as in a discomfort
about their sex and gender being
different
uh what would be a healthy way for us to
deal with that
well i should state i'm i'm not a
clinician i don't do clinical work
anymore and i don't work
with these children um or this
population but i would say more broadly
just from conversations i've had with my
colleagues who do do this work
to just get a sense of what else is
going on in the child's life are there
other reasons for them feeling this way
for a lot of kids who say they are the
opposite sex because that's usually what
critics of p of someone like me will say
well these kids
you can tell the ones who are truly
gender dysphoric from the ones who are
not because they will say i
am the opposite sex but a lot of kids
will say that just because that's the
only language they have to communicate
they want to do things
the opposite sex does so if they if the
parent says you know you're a little boy
you can't play with the easy bake oven
the little
the little boy will say well i am a girl
as a way of saying well i should be able
to do things that girls
do and i think also to look at the
family dynamic and look at you know
other
ways that the child may be using their
gender to maybe get attention from their
parents or get
praise things like that and i mean i
even feel bad saying these things now
because i feel i don't want to make
life more difficult for this you know
trans people
but again no one is saying this stuff
and these are things that are just taken
for granted like we know in the field
that this is these are important
questions to be asking
it makes a lot of sense listen let's
talk about men and women a little bit
and it's a great frustration for francis
and i
uh because we get someone who's
extremely
intelligent well-educated who's written
great stuff who's done amazing research
like you
or jeffrey miller or diana fleischmann
or the
evolutionary psych brett weinstein
whatever and we end up saying
deborah please tell us the difference
between men and women like like
no one knows what it is you know what i
mean but but just
let's talk about that because i think
one of the crucial points you make in
the book is
it's not necessary for people to be
treated equally it's not necessary to
pretend that we're the same
right so what is a man and what is a
woman
i'm a man mate
is that how you identify now is it yeah
country call evidence
well i was gonna say i have a chapter in
the book about sex and dating and i
think
i'm i'm absolutely amazed the number of
young people who reach out to me who are
experiencing mass confusion about how to
approach
romantic relationships even casual sex i
mean it just feels like a it sounds like
an absolute jungle
and um so you know i write in that
chapter about there are differences
between men and women in terms of our
sexual systems and this
serves us very well from an evolutionary
perspective and we don't have to pretend
that men and women are identical in the
bedroom
for us to have equal rights and to have
respect in our relationships and
i'm just i'm amazed at how much
misinformation is out there and
i'm you i would think that most people
like you're saying
know these things but i feel like
there's so much
indoctrination i don't know if it's
because this is what people are being
taught in university but
i sense young people really have they're
lost they're completely lost so what are
some of the key points that people
should just be reminded of
well i would say something like um with
casual sex
i think there's a pressure for young
women to feel like they should have
casual sex or they should enjoy it and
for the most part
i mean almost consistently in the
research it will consistently in the
research men prefer casual sex more than
women and this
this would make sense from an
evolutionary perspective because
for men the investment from sex is much
smaller than for women for women there's
a chance of pregnancy and then also
raising
the child and evolutionary psychology i
think it's a really
bad reputation because people think it's
outdated they say it's sexist
i don't i don't think that's the case i
think by denying these truths
it's actually making life more difficult
for women and men
because we're pretending that these
things don't exist but they very much
exist
and do you think it's making us
miserable deborah in particular women
when we talked to
uh megan murphy the feminist she
actually said that
trying to you know having casual sex and
you know trying to emulate these ideas
is what made her fundamentally miserable
because
it denied a part of who she is
i think for young women especially they
feel like there's something like from
what i when they tell me they feel like
there's something wrong with them that
they are not
more like they're the first straight
women they're not more like their male
partners than that they don't enjoy
casual sex
they do or they are hoping for a
relationship to come out of it for a man
if if you as a woman say to a man you
just want a purely sexual
relationship he's going to be like
fantastic you know and that's that's
really all it is he's not thinking
how will she like me more you know and
and how can i get into a relationship
with her after it's
for for men it's very much if it's sex
it's just sex
and it's considered sexist to say that
but i don't think it should be
well um should i go no no you got me
yeah
and how have we come to this point i
mean before you would have had comedians
in the 1950s you know
doing routines about this we'd all laugh
and we'll go yeah it's funny because
it's true
but now we've come to the point where
this has become controversial
is that not insane i think it is a
little bit yeah
but i think it is coming from the same
place of you know sexism
exists and women have previously had to
deal with
um you know certain uh roadblocks that
they should not have had to deal with
and so i think again it's it's society
going way too far in the opposite
direction and saying okay well
ev in every single way women are the
same as men and especially when it comes
to
sex i think female typical behavior is
somehow seen as
submissive i don't think that's
necessarily the case i think you can be
very assertive as a woman and be very
feminine and that
those two things submissiveness or being
dominated by a partner
being a pushover is not necessarily the
same thing as being feminine
so there i think there's a lot of nuance
that just is not being discussed i think
it's just a lot easier with a lot of
these issues to
create blanket statements or to just be
very very
adamant about one particular perspective
and shut down
any other opposing perspective because
it could potentially be
misused or misconstrued what i find
quite interesting about this whole
world view is that it's almost sexist in
the way that it's designed in that it's
saying like
male quality is good female qualities
bad
uh and you're then forcing women as what
megan murphy was saying you're forcing
women
to think that in order to be
quote-unquote good you have to be like
men
you have to think about sex and
relationships like men
when really that's just we're just not
wired
in the same way are we right and that's
the thing i do think if we pretend again
if we go back to gender being a social
construct if we
say that then that means that men and
male sexuality remain
the gold standard and then female
sexuality is basically
an aberration of that and so women are
going to constantly be
pressured to conform to being like men
and i think it should be perfectly fine
for women to be respected as they are
and but maybe i'm going to misquote you
here but deborah didn't you believe some
of these ideas
early on before doing the research and
then realizing they are
insane as as it were why did you believe
these ideas
because that's what i was told and i
would i you know
that before i started studying sexology
i wasn't exposed to any of the research
data on the other side so uh as a young
woman who was has always been very
outspoken
uh i thought to be of independent
empowered women these are the views that
you hold
and then when i did start studying
sexology in graduate school i realized
that none of those ideas are based in
science and
um and i think it's actually quite
harmful for young women to be told
basically lies because that's not
empowering i think you walk around with
a false sense of empowerment
but you're not informed so that's not
helpful
and he's curious you've said a couple of
times now you kind of
do just to remind everybody that sexism
exists right because sometimes it can
feel like
people are you know on your side of the
argument or perhaps skipping over that
so what are the areas where you think
sexism is still
a powerful force in our society
i definitely would not say in stem i
know that's one very common argument
people
say that the lack of women in stem is
due to sexism and i disagree with that
in the book i
i go through a number of studies that
show that you know actually
when it comes to hiring in terms of
preference for male or female candidates
there's actually a bias in favor of
female candidates for academic positions
um i think that's that's not just true
sorry to interrupt it's not just true
academia
i mean whether it's you know comedy
going
on a panel show as a comedian whether
it's working at the bbc
you know in the mainstream organizations
i suspect if you were to look now 30
years ago
unquestionable bias and failure of men
you look now i think it's either par or
very much in favor of women right
um so but but but i am interested to
think about
you know you said several times that
sexism is still an issue
and i think sometimes people who who are
trying to have
a conversation on our side of the fence
if you like if there is a side of the
fence
uh you know sometimes skip over things
so where do you think sexism is still
is still an issue well i think on an
individual level it's not possible to go
through every single person in society
and to
cleanse their mind of any negative
thoughts of women
or anyone who believes that women are
inferior in some way to
completely eradicate that so i think in
that way but i don't think it's
it's at a systemic level and i don't
think it's in a way that's really
seriously holding
women back certainly not in western
society
so there's a few [ __ ] basically just
still walking around
right and that's not that yeah and
that's not to say that those
interactions
aren't um uncomfortable
for somebody or upsetting for somebody
but i i do think in the grand scheme of
things you can choose in life what you
want to focus on and what's going to
motivate you or hold you back
and i you know i write in the book of
about some some situations i experience
with sexism but
i think if you stay focused as a woman
and you just keep moving forward then
there's nothing that's going to stop you
in that way agreed and anyway that's
enough about constantine so let's move
on
[Laughter]
right i was gonna rush i can't even
argue back it's my culture it's my
cancer what can i do
yeah i'm problematic mate now um but
deborah one thing that really came
forward in your book and the thing that
i found very interesting is you made the
point that we are having these com these
incredibly complex nuanced conversations
and a lot of people hosting these
conversations are quite frankly
not qualified to do so he's talking
about me
[Laughter]
but at least we don't pretend to be
qualified
but do you think that why do you think
that's
bad and do you actually think it's quite
dangerous as well
well when you say their hosts are not
qualified in what way are they not
qualified
so like people commenting about sex and
gender are not people
from a scientific background they're
people from the humanities and arts and
as somebody who's got a degree in the
arts i can say i'm qualified for nothing
but i would say even experts this is the
this is what's so
crazy right now is that i feel i feel
bad even using the word crazy because
that's not supposed to be a problematic
term but
you know that even scientific experts
some of them have become ideological
and that they will say things like
you know there are no biologically based
differences in the brain between men and
women and you see
the new research that's coming out
saying these things so
it's it's really a frightening time
because now the scientific
papers themselves are compromised
because scientists know it's one thing
to say
whatever loopy idea you have but it's
not until you publish that in a paper
and then you can point to that paper and
say oh yeah in this paper that we
published we showed this
magically and you know it so that's
that's where we are right now
but i i don't see maybe i'm not being
how can how but surely science is
science it's fact isn't it
if you are a good scientist you will
design your study in a way that it's not
biased and that you you'll be open to
whatever you find at the end so i don't
want to necessarily point fingers at
people in terms of what they're doing
but definitely in the fields when a
paper comes out that says something like
there are no
biologically based sex differences in
the brain it you can
if you look at all of the previous
research i mean there's hundreds and
hundreds of studies
suggesting otherwise and and when
most of the experts in the field if not
all who are not ideological
are saying this is not this does not
look right and you go in and even so for
say one study that was published showing
there are no sex differences when a
different group of my colleagues
analyzed the exact same data from the
study
they found that you could tell the
difference between male and female
brains at a rate much higher than chance
so i mean i think again i don't want to
be pointing fingers but
you can if you want to promote a
particular agenda
even as a scientist you can find a way
to do that right and what will happen
to the way we have these conversations
because one of the other things you talk
about
in the book is essentially people who
want to do authentic science unbiased
they know the punishment as you said
yourself even tenure won't protect you
and then of course those people leave
the field and we've seen a lot of people
um leaving different
uh academic branches because they
recognize that they can't do the
research that they want to do
because if they find the wrong thing
they're going to be punished for it
and will that not lead over time to
essentially a replacement of
true scientists with gender driven
ideologically driven signs
and then all of the stuff that you're
saying is
scientifically not true will become
scientifically true
right that is what we're seeing right
now and especially when it comes to
gender if you look at
well the research pretending to say
children with gender dysphoria
i'm not really questioning what new
studies are going to find because
we know that we see what happens if you
try to
question or challenge transgender the
trans
what narrative is being put forward by
trans activists there was a study that
was published
last year that suggested that gender
dysphoria
may have something to do with sensory
networks and that it may not necessarily
be due to
having the wrong brain sex in someone's
body so
i think that's not necessarily the case
for everybody but i do think that paper
was published for the purpose
of uh sparking debate that's that's why
the journal published it
and then it ended up being put under
review again and then it was eventually
retracted
because there was such an outcry over it
because people were saying
this could be misused to say that trans
people should not
transition i think that's usually the
key fear and i understand that fear
because again medical gatekeeping did
exist and i don't think trans people
i think they deserve support and care
and to be able to access
you know the interventions adults should
be and
so now no one's going to touch this
subject no
good ethical research is going to touch
the subject so instead all the research
that's coming out is going to be
activist
led and we've talked about the impact on
trans people and i think it's important
that
all of us just like you have emphasized
that
we want people who are showing the
dysphoric to get the support that they
need
uh absolutely and for adults to be able
to live their life as they choose
there's no i don't think uh people have
any issue with that
but but there's also another population
that feels very threatened by what's
happening
from the other end which is women uh
or cervix have us as the cnn today
menstruating yeah uterus uterus
exactly well there's two ejaculators the
question we'd like to ask
um uh is uh you know
women feel very strongly about this
issue as we've discovered over the time
that we've been doing the show
uh francis he's holding his lips there
women do feel very strongly about this
issue uh
what do you have a particular view on
that because
uh you know it's become a big
contentious issue in fact i would say
almost all of the contentiousness comes
from
that women feeling like they're under
attack by some of this
do you what's your take on that i think
with regard to because i think the
broader conversation is about are
transgender women
the same as women who were born women
full stop
because the implications of that are
much different from if we were to say
trans men are the same as men full stop
because
when it comes to women's spaces
women are arguably going to be affected
more so
if someone who is a trans woman is
and when i when i cite these criticisms
my issue is not with
trans people it's because the policy
then opens up the opportunity for
individuals who are male who are not
transgender
for them to abuse the ability to access
these spaces
back to biological differences men are
bigger stronger blah blah blah
right and also i mean they are more
likely to perpetuate sexual offenses
not all men of course but that's just
the reality of someone who has worked
with sex offenders previously in
research and
clinically so i think it's important to
be able to talk about this issue
depending
on the particular context and the
factors involved so bathrooms
prisons sports shelters you know i think
right now people are taking a very much
a sweeping approach saying either either
if they're in favor of trans rights they
say 100
trans women are women that's that's the
end of it
and you know to suggest otherwise is
bigoted
and then on the other side people are
saying no trans women
are not the same as women and you know
so
uh i mean we can talk about maybe the
specific concept
right well let's talk about it because
how do you resolve that for example
you know you take a kind of balanced
sensible view of it
um should trans women have access to
female
only bathrooms prisons sports
i mean they're all slightly different
but um you know just talk us
through your view on those on those
contexts
i think my my biggest point of
contention would be prisons 100
you cannot i mean we are seeing now with
male sex offenders so they they will
commit sexual offenses against
female victims and they will be arrested
and then they will
they will identify as female and they
will have to be not only recorded as
female
by the police but then they will be
potentially housed in
a women's prison and i just i
it's just beyond me i don't know as
anyone who works in forensics
should know that that is not a good idea
so
this is actually happening um i think
again it's
it's very possible that a prisoner may
decide to come out as trans maybe they
are truly gender dysphoric and
and so in which case yeah that should be
taken into account but i think
you know a psychologist when you are
evaluating these populations
your job is to determine what is the
likelihood of reoffending that's the
biggest thing like
level of risk that someone is going to
recidivate and
it's almost like that's not being
considered at all in these
these discussions it's very much all
about identity and that's really really
not helpful and it's it's dangerous
yeah there's a very famous case in the
uk with a person called karen white
who's a male sex offender
i think a rapist actually identified as
a woman
uh got put in a women's prison and lo
and behold went on to sexually abuse
three or four women
and you do start to think at that point
you had society
and the world taken leave of its senses
yeah yeah that's the thing
what else can you say you know yeah i
mean i imagine your take on
trans women and female sports would be
along similar lines and that there's a
biological difference hence
they can't compete with each other would
that be right
right i mean i think and i again i i
think
i feel it almost feels insensitive to
say this because in some way it's saying
that again
pointing to the differences between
trans women and women who are born women
and by saying that there are differences
sometimes it can feel as though you are
telling them how they should identify
who they really are
but i think it's important to be able to
talk about these things especially
because
they are a scientific reality because in
some cases like
sports like mixed martial arts which is
one of my favorite sports somewhat if
a trans woman is fighting in the women's
division
there's a chance that that person can be
very badly hurt or even killed
and i don't think it's fair to the
female competitors to just tell them
well just you need to suck it up and
work harder
that's i mean or you look at the cases
of young women who are
going competing for scholarships and you
have
um trans girls competing with them and
just basically
obliterating them it's it's not fair
and where do you stand and this is the
most well
those are of course contentious issues
the whole thing is contentious
but let's talk about women's bathrooms
and women's safe spaces
where do you stand on that do you think
that posey does that a
women's bathroom is a completely safe
space and
only women should be allowed in them or
do you have slightly more flexibility
with your
ideas bathrooms myself personally
as an a grown woman i have less of an
issue i think i'm i'm
me personally i'm fine if trans women
want to use women's bathrooms however
i don't think it's fair that women and
especially girls
who are upset by this or who are
concerned about this i don't think it's
fair to tell them
that they are hateful just for having an
opposing view i think that they should
be able to have
it speak their perspective and that we
should be able to have an open dialogue
about this something like shelters
though i am a little bit
more critical because you know you're
going to be
sleeping next to a complete stranger
potentially and for a lot of the
women who are in these shelters they
have a history of trauma some of them
have sexual trauma some of them have
issues with substance abuse and it can
be
you know they will relive trauma by
potentially being around someone who
especially if this person is
preoperative right if it's a
preoperative trans woman so i think
those factors need to be taken into
account
and women's concerns need to be taken
more seriously instead of simply
dismissed
all right well uh we're almost out of
time before we ask
our last question and it's been a great
interview and uh wonderful speaking with
you
uh how do we be besides everybody you
get in your book
at the end of gender and reading it etc
how do we get out of this into some kind
of healthy
way of looking at all these issues
because i don't think it's an issue
that's going away i think there will
always be
trans people and there will always be
some kind of tension between
uh the desire to for them to have their
rights respected and for
other people in society whose rights are
affected by that that will always
continue
but how do we find a more healthy way of
speaking about it and a healthy way of
behaving about it
i think the main thing is that the vocal
minority really needs to know that they
are sorry not the focal minority the
vocal majority no needs to know that
they are the majority
that's the thing because so many people
reach out to me and tell me
that a lot of these ideas don't make
sense to them i mean it's it's
really concerning the level to which we
are being
saturated in our culture with these
nonsensical ideas like gender as a
spectrum
or that uh biological sex or is whatever
you want it to be you can identify
however you want and you choose it
yourself
and things like that it's completely
nonsensical
it's not scientific and yet people
people sense that something is not right
but they're not sure how so yeah in the
book i do talk about
all the scientific literature that can
help you fight back against that
misinformation
but yeah i think just to know that no
you you're right
the way you feel you have a reason for
feeling that way and it's okay to say
that it doesn't make you a bad person to
say that
deborah it's been a wonderful wonderful
interview we've really really
enjoyed it the uh question that we
always finish all our interviews with is
always the same
it's what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society and that we
really should be
i would say the biggest thing for me
when we take a step back would be that
science denial whether it's coming from
the left or the right
is really not helpful so my book
is predominantly calling out
left-leaning science now i would still
call myself a liberal
and funnily enough the majority of sex
researchers are liberal
but i think part of the reason why we've
gotten to where we are is because
we liberals don't it's difficult to call
it your own side because you almost feel
like
you don't know how or you question
especially for as a
sex researcher interference from the
right has predominantly been
the issue that they face so not to say
that all right lean people have issue
with
sex research but i think when it is your
own side it's just as important to
to call it out because it's just as
harmful and it's going to lead to just
as
as much misinformation and bad things
for society
and i can say to everybody calling out
your own side really does end well
yes that has been our experience but uh
yeah we have got a new studio eventually
um so uh having been kicked out of our
last one for not being woken up
anyway uh enough about us uh it's a
brilliant book the end of gender make
sure you go and get it we'll put the
link in the bottom of the video dr
deborah so it's been an absolute
pleasure
speaking we wish you all the best and
i'm sure we'll speak to you again very
soon
thank you so much good luck to you guys
too thank you very much deborah and
if you want to catch uh another show or
a live stream
we are broadcasting tuesday wednesday
thursday friday saturday and sunday
episodes go out on wednesday and sunday
and everything is always at 7pm uk time
at 7 p.m uk time see you soon guys
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word